they're number of symbols on the wall
some of them are supposed to remind us
of patterns we've seen before going back
to the very first geometric pattern on
the show which was the weird array of
body parts that the way walkers made one
of the things we learn from these cave
paintings is that the white wall
Christian come up with those images they
derived them from their creators the
children the forest these are patterns
that have mystical significance for the
children the forest we're not sure
exactly what they signify but spiral
patterns are important a lot of
different cultures in our world and make
sense that they would be in this world
as well everybody is Charlie so I got a
lot of requests to explain the children
of the forest symbols just because
they've shown up so many times in the
history of the TV show the White Walkers
make them the children of the forest
have all kinds of different drawings but
they seem to be the same couple of
different symbols over and over on the
cave wall everybody came up with that
great joke the Jon Snow was secretly
scribbling those on the wall to get
Daenerys to believe him but in reality
thousands of years ago the children of
the forest visited Dragonstone lived
here and used the dragon glass to give
to the first men to help fight the White
Walkers the drawings essentially depict
the creation of the White Walkers but
you keep seeing this Fibonacci series
symbol all over the place you have these
seven spirals coming out there are a
couple of geometric patterns that go
back to the first episode which is a
slightly different pattern this one here
and then there's another different one
that has a leaf in the center here which
actually appears on the rock where Ned
Stark beheads the first man who's
deserted the Nights Watch so the idea is
that the children of the forest have
recorded their story so that anyone like
Jon Snow or Daenerys could walk in it
understand who the others are and what
their purpose is and what their
connection to the children of the forest
is because there are a lot of
metaphorical meanings to this symbol and
there are a lot of practical reasons
some of the metaphors are a little bit
different for each of the characters
because a lot of you probably noticed
the Fibonacci series the golden ratio or
like the symbol that appears in nature
like flower petals so just like the
Druids built Stonehenge to sort of
commune with nature and use it
practically as an astrological calendar
the
symbol with the seven spirals of rocks
arranged around it like the seven arms
represents the cycle of nature but
practically like if you've seen West
world the maze represents the
metaphorical journey through the
labyrinth of one's mind to consciousness
is also a representation of the
connection of the past present and
future so like brand travels the
pathways of the weirwoods to see into
the past the weirwood at the center sort
of like the World Tree represents the
connection of all the different planes
of existence it's like yeah gristle so
in a sense the children of the forest
worshipping nature Mother Earth this is
also like a womb so for Daenerys for
instance it has different metaphors like
she literally birthed the new dragon
she's reborn among salt and smoke the
night King is born here so in those
instances they invoked the power of the
earth it becomes a much more literal
womb as they're reborn even though we
only saw a little of it on the TV show
we know the children of the forest were
using the weirwood caves as shelter they
were using it as a literal womb hiding
within the womb of their mother there's
a whole lot that you don't really get
from this scene here but the way that
the producers explain it is that they
just wanted to imply that there was
prehistory here before the Targaryens
ever came the children is a forest told
their story even though the symbols
depict a story the symbols themselves
have greater meaning to a Song of Ice
and Fire
the idea that this is like one of those
French caves where prehistoric man lived
and painted on the walls except in our
case it wasn't in prehistoric men but
children of forests supposed to be
something that's very evocative of the
thousands of years of the past case were
first explored and the paintings were
first made and also obviously something
that's quite relevant to the current
storyline because it's about how these
two disparate peoples United to fight
the common enemy so on the TV show Dan
and Dave said that the White Walkers
learned those symbols from the children
of the forest so they keep drawing them
and implied that it's more to mock them
in a showing of that cycle of nature so
it's been date the long summer now it is
time for the long night it is our time
now in more practically on the show just
to reference visually where they came
from so you could have looked at this
way back when mance rayder found it
always an artist in thought hey you know
maybe they have something to do with the
children of the forest maybe they come
from them and that was way back during
season three always made artists
[Music]
so my horses
no man said there was dead crows it was
I'll buy the rental a 300 so it all
comes back to the idea that the real
deity here that they might be worshiping
is the earth like this is the children
of the force worship the old gods they
worship the weirwood the weirwood is the
representation of the earth some mother
so it does raise a lot of questions
about the supernatural forces in
Westeros because this whole time
especially in the books we've known that
there are two big sides to this there's
rule or the red gods at the red priests
worship and then you have the great
other that suppose a deity of the others
all we really know that is the
inspiration the George R Martin took was
from Zoroastrianism so you sort of have
night day these two opposing forces that
fight back and forth the cycle of day
and night so it remains to be seen how
literal the TV show gets with that but
they seem to be more metaphorical with
it like I think we're probably not going
to get too many more explainers on the
show about what these symbols mean it's
just meant to visually tie the White
Walkers to the children of the forest
and show where they came from like this
was the womb that gave birth to me just
like this womb help gave birth to the
Dragons as well as Daenerys being reborn
most of the people that were watching
this scene we're talking mostly about
Daenerys and Jon Snow coming together or
talking about their relationship but
even if he doesn't understand it what
Jon Snow is trying to get across to
Daenerys is is that we're all connected
we all need to come together so a sort
of a reminder of the idea of one earth
one organism like we all evolved on this
we're all connected in the fundamental
level but the idea of the cycle the
spiral Daenerys said last season that
she wants to break the wheel they want
to break the cycle so that it doesn't
happen again so that in another thousand
years there isn't another Jon Snow that
comes along talking about the night King
what's going to be different about this
time that's the big question what was
different about those previous times
that caused the cycle to perpetuate make
sure he bros even talks about the idea
of many winters coming and going every
winter has an end into summer every
summer has an end into winter so let me
know in the comments what do you think
is going to be different about this time
that's going to help them break the
wheel like break the cycle you'll
probably notice the problem with that
metaphor - breaking the cycle because is
law
long as planet OHS or whatever you want
to call the planet in Game of Thrones
cycles around their Sun in their solar
system there will be day and night there
will be winter there will be summer in
seasons so that might just be a place
where the narrative breaks down a little
bit like the metaphor doesn't apply to
everything it just only applies to
Daenerys practically stopping everybody
from fighting in Westeros but what will
happen tonight is I'll post my episode 5
video I was going to do a video about
dragon bonding and warding but I'll
probably wait til next week to do that
just because there's so much stuff
that's happening in this episode leave
all your requests for bonus videos in
the comments below and I'll announce a
new winner to the giveaway when I post
my episode 5 video tonight all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so while
you wait for everything you can click
here for that episode 5 video I'll add a
link when I post that and you can click
here to learn all about Aria's dad thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight